hello my name is Lata I'm a smother
process offering manager at IBM today I
am going to give you a demonstration of
IBM operational decision manager on
cloud before starting the demonstration
I want to give you a short introduction
of what IBM odm on cloud is first of all
IBM operationalization manager on cloud
is a collaborative software as a service
that is role based and the aim of REM on
cloud is to help you to capture automate
and manage all your frequently occurring
business decisions that are was based
then you will be able to share them
across the cloud IBM or DM on cloud is a
software service cloud that is hosted on
the IBM cloud platform based on
SoftLayer this means that this service
is available on the 17 different IBM
SoftLayer data center worldwide the
concept of operation of odm on cloud is
very simple everything start from the
role designer the Eclipse environment
for developers that have the
responsibility of designing the decision
service configuring the decision service
defining all the models the vocabulary
the business user will use and the
various deployment configuration and
then the service is pushed to the cloud
then everything will happen from the
cloud so the business expert in charge
of maintaining the business policy will
have access to all the rules they are
able to update them view then test then
do some simulation define their own
testing and simulation suite and
validating all the change or Yemen cloud
also provides some predefined governance
services with the decision governance
framework that comes out of the box with
the service Orion cloud comes with three
different
environment development test and
production as we will see the release
manager is in charge of pushing the
various versions of the decisions
depending on the update and depending of
the lifecycle as they are in into one of
these different environments where we
see the sridevi test and production
environment in the demonstration finally
the external application will invoke
this decision service providing the
input data and then getting in as a
result so decisions also connections
from outside to the clouds are secured
and performed through HTTPS we volume
and cloud you can define as many
different decisions as you were used to
do with the odium on pram you can do
some fraud detection and the writing
claims eligibility pricing loyalty so
all the classical rules based decisions
that you were used to develop with the
odium on-prem are also available and you
can also develop similar decisions from
IBM odm on cloud in today's
demonstration we are going to see a
simple fast LAN decision service so from
a fast run web application any customer
are able to provide their data to get a
loan from the bank the first condition
services are set on ODM on cloud and
provide different services validation
scoring and an eligibility to the lawn
the rigid manager in our demonstration
will be responsible for updating the
business policies and pushing them into
the various dev test and prod
environment depend depending on where we
are in the update lifecycle so let's now
move to the demonstration
so before having a look to ODM include
let's see this client application so
from this application any customer can
provide the details are their name age
all the data that the roots will use to
decide about the validation about the
scoring and the eligibility to zero
behind the scene we are going to use the
audio Mon cloud invocation to the
service from this sample interface we
can decide to invoke the rules from the
Deaf that also production environment as
any HTTP connection so we have to
provide the credentials or the username
and the password
to be able to access the cloud instance
that he's here located here in that URL
so let's use with this as a data this
decision service so here I have
submitted the data to the service and
automatically I see that my Lord has
been rejected I can see some reasons so
I can see the scores that has been
computed by the rules and run reason the
DEP to income was too high compared to
the credit score I got with my data if I
just change a value here for example
increasing my ele income and invoke a
new decision here the result is
different because now I am eligible with
my DEP to income ratio that is good for
the opt-in score so all the score and
decisions are managed behind the scene
by the business whose decision service
so let's see what's behind the scene so
let's first log in into a DM on cloud so
here I can provide my credentials and
then my password
and now I enter ODM on cloud so this is
the landing page of idiom on cloud so as
I've explained previously you can see
that audience cloud is composed of three
environments the development environment
in which you will see as a rule designer
the decision center business console and
the press console that has a two
consoles that are designed for business
user to update manage their business
policies and the rule execution server
console that provides a visibility on
the dedicated execution server instance
that is available on this development
environment then we have a test
environment where we will just have the
rule exaction server console to manage
all the decisions that are deployed on
the test environment and the finally the
production environment once again with
the rule addiction server console
allowing me to see all the decisions
that have been deployed in the
production environment
so in the previous example with the with
a small demo that we have seen we were
executing the decision from that
environment the production one so any as
I said in the introduction aureum and
cloud is a role based service this means
that here I'm logged as a an
administrator this means that I can see
all the administration panel and have
access to all the users and privileges
from the users that are here in the in
this instance I can rapidly invite a new
user just by here setting an email and
then automatically odium on cloud we
send an invitation email to this user
allowing him first to set up his account
his name and password and then finally
access the the cloud instance so from
from this from this interface so you can
filter here so you can see here my
profile
I'm on an MS writer
and Here I am the my role is a release
manager that is the highest role with
the highest privileges that you can have
in your demon cloud so in just one click
you can change the roles of the users
and that will give them access to some
specific functions and features as a
product or just block them for example
deploy in the production environment is
something that is just allowed for
release managers as I am right now let's
come back not to that to go to the day's
audition service so as I said so
everything starts from the rule designer
so from this environment you can
download the rule designer archive that
and you will get the entire
configuration figure Eclipse environment
that allows any developer to setup the
decision service before pushing it to
the cloud let's have a look to this
environment rapidly so here we are into
the Eclipse environment we are in the
root perspective and we can see here our
decision service the first one's service
demo with the eligibility scurrying and
invalidation rosette that that are
composing here our global decision we
can see here is a would flow that
orchestrate these various rule rule sets
one important aspect of of a decision
service is the deployment configurations
so here we have defined two
configuration one that will allow a user
to deploy on non production environments
and here we can see all the servers that
are available on the crawl on the cloud
and that are non production environment
so we can see the one from the
development environment and one from the
test environment when you specify in the
rule designer your cloud connection
specifying the URL using your username
and your password automatically here all
the URL for the values
execute environments are automatically
set we can see here the production
configuration once again with the
production environment predefined with
the correct URL once defined you can
synchronize your decision service with
the decision Center just by clicking on
this button automatically all your
decision service will be pushed to your
cloud instance from them any business
users and release manager are able to
access this decision service from the
cloud
so let's come back to the cloud and have
a look to the design service so to do so
I'm going to use today the business
console so the business console is the
web interface that is specially designed
for business users allowing them to
collaborate exchange using the social
media style collaborations and and
update their decisions so here we can
see all the decisions that are already
deployed on this instance and I'm going
to have a look to the first LAN service
that that compose today or today's
demonstration so there are two options
in Aoyama unplug you can either work
with the decision governance framework
where you will be completely guided
end-to-end in a governance we're in a
governed way to update business
decisions using dedicated activities or
use the branch mode so let's use the
other branch mode and have a look to all
the rules and decisions that are
governing or today's demonstration so
here we can see once again all the rules
that have been defined and that you can
update so we can see for example here a
decision table so the decision tables
that will initialize the score depending
on the state of the residence of the
customer and and all of the of the
borrower and the fact the the flag that
tells us if the the request comes from
an existing customer of the bank or not
depending on these parameters we will
initialize the score accordingly so here
we have seen a decision table you can
also define a decision using textual
rules so here we can see one of these
rule is the amount of the loan is more
than 500,000 and the borrower is is the
easily is not an existing customer then
we will add a message to the learner the
N and then we will reject the learn
directly so here we are in an
eligibility rule as I said an important
aspect of of OD among on cloud and on
the business console is the ability for
business user-defined to define a
simulation suite here from that
environment so here we have some
predefined matrix some KPIs that the
user have as have a F defined some data
that they want to use for the simulation
they can also define the way they want
the report to be displayed and all these
different items will define what we call
a simulation so the simulation really
execute all the rules in the current
status and against all the data that are
defined here in the in the data file and
we'll compute some predefined KPI so
let's start the simulation here we can
see the statues so the simulation is
ongoing and no simulation is done let's
have a look to the report as it has been
defined by the business user so we can
see here in that in that report first
that 28 loans has been a
five of them have been rejected among
these five rejected lawns for wear
existing customers here we can see
different ways for representing the KPIs
and so using some pipe shots so here we
can see that 15 percent of the incoming
requests were rejected we can see that
most of the of the reject rejection
where for existing customers and the
approval ratio per state so here all the
data that we can n can display an KPI
that we can display here are completely
defined from this interface by business
users so we can see that the the number
of rejected customer is a is is very
high so this is risky for for the
insurance because more of your customer
you will reject the more likely they
will be to go to another bank so in
order to reduce this this attrition the
business user decide to try to solve
this issue or reduces the risk by
creating in your wall so let's see how
you can do that in a DMM cloud so the
first thing is to come to the rule and
here in the scoring we will increase the
score for existing customer so here we
have a bonus rule set in this bonus rule
set we are going to to create a new rule
let's call it an existing customers and
we are going to use the interior editor
that is a contextual pointing click
editor with automatic completion that
allows me to define my rules very easily
so if the borrower and then
automatically I've got some automatic
complexity completion is not is an
existing customer then I'm going to
increase the score of the borrower by
200 points and then I'm going to
document this this rule by adding a mess
agent so we are going to call message an
existing customer bonus and then we are
going to set this message to the loan
here we are so the rule is Deva this is
defined I have no more error here I can
save the rule and create a new version
of that rule the rule is not yet
deployed but we can already measures
impactors that fool so what we are going
to do here is to just come back into the
simulation and run the exact same
simulation as the previous one using the
same data so a new report is being
generated and we are going to see the
impact of that new rule so here the new
report is here and what I can do is
compare side-by-side this new report
with the previous one so that I can
really see the impact of my new policy
here I can see that the previous number
of existing customer was four and no is
it is just three and here we have also
reduced the number of existing customers
that were rejected so as a business user
but I will say this rule does it job and
it reduced the number of rejected
existing customers so the next step for
me is to make sure that this rule does
not break the integrity of my system to
do so so I'm going to use a test suite
that also has been defined
from the business console and run this
Vista Street on my new rules so a test
should consist in defining some are some
scenarios and check the result for each
scenarios if one result with the rules
is not matching the expected conditions
the expected results then we will get
some arrows so let's run the test suite
here so behind the scene so we are
executing all the routes including the
new one and we can see the the test
report so all the tests are successful
this means that the new rules that have
created is not breaking the integrity of
my system for example here for this
scenario the long approach that you was
supposed to be true
and the result is true so here the
credit score of the borrower for that
scenario was supposed to be greater
greater than 400 it has been 7 170 so
all the scenarios and all the condition
are matched for or in rkg so 100% of
succeed of success so this means that ok
my new rule does not break my integrity
the integrity of the system and now I
can deploy it for further tests to do
that I am a realist manager so I have
the ability to deploy on the other
values environment so here we can see
the two deployment configuration that we
have defined in the rule designer and
deploy in one of these environments so
the first thing I'm going to do is
deploy on the test environment so let's
do this so now the deployment is ongoing
and it's done from my cloud instance so
I can come to the test environment and
start the rule addiction server console
and check that my decision has been
correctly deployed so here I can see my
last cloud deployment for my
this in-service and here C is a new
version of my first one service for set
data that have just undeployed right now
so my service my new distance service is
deployed on the test environment so if I
come back to my testing interface what I
can do now is using the test environment
and start a new learn evaluation and
here I can see that normal my loan has
been accepted and the result the score
is is no 290 and we can see that my
existing customer bonus rule has been
fired for that case if I come back to
the production environment we execute
the exact same case we are still
rejected just because we have not yet
deployed on production so Orion on cloud
allows you to really run and test on and
do some validation and testing without
impacting your production environment so
now what I can see here in this
pre-production test is that my new
decision service works well with my
client application so the next step for
me is to deploy the rule into the
production environment so let's do that
using this specific deployment
configuration once again I am a real
advantage ER so I am entitled to to
deploy on that environment once again
from the cloud interface so I can have a
look to the word addiction server in
production and see all my rules that
have been a rule rule application that
have been deployed and once again the
new version of my decision service that
has been deployed in production Here I
am still using the the application in
production model it is still running I'm
really cuting again just the exact same
case and now I am allowed allowed to to
get the loan and and
once again I can see the existing
customer bonus role that has been fired
so this means that you can deploy new
business policies and update your
application or business processes with
odium and cloud without interrupting the
service itself so it brings you a great
visibility so in this demonstration so
we have been able to see odm inclusion
action we have been able to see how
business users can update rules and run
some testing simulation measures the
impact of the changes before putting
them into production we have seen the
values lifecycle for the rules starting
from the dev environment the test
environment and then the production
environment and we also we have also
been able to see how easy it is in a
daemon cloud to manage roles and assign
a new participant invite new a
participant to the cloud instance so to
conclude this this presentation let me
give you some some some takeaways so
here are some top the top 10 values that
you can get from odm on cloud
so we've odm on cloud you benefit from
decades of investments and innovation
from IBM on the business roots
management system domain the service is
provisioned in less than 48 hours so you
are able to create your first decision
very rapidly so service is as I said
fully managed by IBM meaning that you
will not require any IT investment to
operate it so it's mostly subscription
model gives you a flexibility and a
visibility on your investments are you
include being a software as a service
you will not need servers to run it so
it reduces capex capital expenditure for
your organization the user management is
self-service as we have seen it does not
require any contact to IBM to invite you
participant and assign them with roles
you can do that by yourself
I know DM on cloud instance comes as we
have seen with the three death test and
production environments making the
decision update cycle straightforward
the service is secured and kept secured
by IDM the Orion version are always up
to date on this service and IBM will
push the new features on the regular
basis are on the cloud so an audio Mon
cloud helps you to control your
investment by cutting down license cost
you choose a hardware investment people
required to maintain and operate the
system and Sally it configure it update
it all the stars cannot fully perform
for you by IBM with security
so some next step so the first thing you
can do is to learn more about Orion all
Club visiting the OEM death Center you
have here the URL or also visiting the
ODN product page on IBM dot-com site
then you can evaluate an IBM of
virtualization manager on cloud signing
up for a two week free trial version
from where you will have a full access
to the product you have here the link to
request your trial version and finally
we can do some on-site workshop on with
your business and users and IT
stakeholders and then during this
workshop we will evaluate the
applicability of volume on cloud for
your project thank you for your
attention and have a nice day